Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Gözde Zülal Solak
Aslında, tabii ki belli oluyor ki
buraya konuşmak için geldim değil mi?
Gitarımla falan. Hayır.
Tabii ki müzik yapmaya
geldim, iyi bir konuşmacı değilim,
ama derdimi müzikle daha iyi anlatıyorum.
Beni bu yüzden buraya çağırdılar.
Olduğum gibi olmalıyım bence.
Doğru mu? Evet.
(Alkış)
Umarım beğenirsiniz.
(Müzik başlar)
Şu sılanın ufak tefek yolları
Ağrıdan sızıdan tutmaz elleri
Tepeden tırnağa şiir dilleri
Yiğidim aslanım burda yatıyor
Bugün efkârlıyım açmasın güller
Yiğidimden kara haber verdiler
Demirden döşeği taştan sedirler
Yiğidim aslanım burda yatıyor
Burda yatıyor
(Alkış)
Bir gün anneme sormuştum,
dedim ki anne dedim,
parçalarımı, şarkılarımı,
düzenlemelerimi beğeniyor musun dedim.
Sonra annem de bana dedi ki,
''Tabii ki beğeniyorum oğlum,'' dedi.
Ben de anneme dedim ki,
anne dedim gerçekten sırf beni sevdiğin
için söylüyorsun değil mi bunu, dedim.
Annem de dedi ki, hayır dedi,
gerçekten sen iyi olduğun için,
binlerce kişiye şarkı söyleyeceksin, dedi.
O yüzden beni doğuran ve büyüten
anneme teşekkür ediyorum buradan.
(Alkış)
Bir sonraki parçamız da,
ismi ''Ah Bir Ataş Ver.''
Umarım beğenirsiniz,
bu da çok güzel bir türkümüzdür.
Ah bir ataş ver,
cigaramı yakayım
Sen salın gel,
ben boyuma bakayım
Uzun olur gemilerin direği
Ah çatal olur,
efelerin yüreği
Ah yanık olur,
anaların yüreği
Uzun olur,
gemilerin direği
Ah çatal olur,
efelerin yüreği
Ah yanık olur,
anaların yüreği
(Alkış)
Yanıma şimdi bir can yoldaşımı,
böyle kardeşimi davet etmek istiyorum.
Kaliforniya'da doğmuş, Ümraniye'de
büyümüş bir adam, falan dermişim.
''Lovely Umraniye'' der yaşadığı yere.
İsmi Ed Pithey.
Bir alkış alabilir miyiz Ed'e lütfen.
(Alkış)
Şimdi, ben 13 yaşından
beri blues dinliyorum,
blues ve caz.
13 yaşında Ray Charles'ın filmini
izledikten sonra, voaav diye böyle
o ışıkla, şu ışıkları gözlerimde
hayal ettim, böyle parıl parıl parladım,
o filmden sonra, blues'a
böyle bir aşkla bağlandım.
Böyle nasıl insanın damarında arabesk olur
benim de damarımda hep blues geziyor.
Böyle blues blues blues diye.
E sürekli bir şekilde harmanladım,
mesela blues bir omlet olsun,
sürekli yemeklerim omletli makarna,
omletli omlet, işte sürekli içinde
bir yumurta var ama yani hani
ne yaparsam yapayım.
Bizim müziğimiz de topraktan geliyor,
onların müziği de topraktan geliyor.
Böyle ikisi çok güzel harmanlanıyor.
Şimdi size
''Uzun İnce Bir Yoldayım'' çalacağız,
ama sürpriz bir parçayla beraber.
Uzun ince bir yoldayım
Gidiyorum gündüz gece
Bilmiyorum ne haldayım
Gündüz gece
Gündüz gece, vay
Bilmiyorum ne haldayım
Gidiyorum gündüz gece
Gündüz gece
Gündüz gece, vay
Ain't no sunshine when she's gone
It's not warm when she's away
And she's always gone too long,
anytime she goes away
Wonder this time where she's gone
Wonder if she's gone to stay
Ain't no sunshine when she's gone
And she's always gone too long,
anytime she goes away
And I know, I know, I know, I know, I know
Bilmiyorum ne haldayım
Gidiyorum gündüz gece
Gündüz gece
Gündüz gece, vay
Gündüz
Gece vay
Bilmiyorum, ne haldayım
Gidiyorum gündüz gece
Gündüz gece
Paşam sizi çok seviyorum,
iyi ki bu ülkedeyim.
Vay
29 Ekim Cumhuriyet Bayramınız
kutlu olsun arkadaşlar.
Bu ülkeyi sevin tamam mı?
Size ihtiyacımız var.
(Alkış)